we continue our discussion of
sat and its complexity uh
last time we talked about and the
completeness of sat which is a huge
result of course and
and you probably know i'm sure you know
that there are lots of other
anti-complete problems out there
however the picture of the class mp is
not black and white
as was discovered by ladner in 1975 very
soon after the discovery on
the completeness showed that
assuming p is different from np there
will exist
problems in the class and p of
intermediate complexity
meaning that they will not be
np-complete
but they will not be polynomial time
solvable either
so there will be something in the middle
over here
but sat and different variants of sad
seem to be very special
so we don't expect and we can probably
show that
neither none of this natural set
variants
can be of that intermediate complexity
problem
so that was discovered um
by shaffer in 1978 and he said
look there are different set variants
that you can naturally define and some
of them
we already seen earlier there's two sat
where you talk about satisfiability of
formulas where each clause is of
size two and we know it's in polynomial
time
i mentioned that before we also know
that three sound is empty complete
but let's talk about other sub variants
that can be polynomial time
if you talk about system of linear
equations
xor sat you also can solve it in
polynomial time using gaussian
elimination
there's a special kinds of formulas
called hornstat
where you have clauses where each clause
has at most one positive literal in it
and if you have a conjunction of such
clauses then satisfiability of such
formulas
is possible in polynomial time not
trivial along with them
i won't go into that and similarly if
you have so-called dual horn clauses
only
these are clauses which have at most one
negative literal in them
then the conjunction of such clauses is
a
sub instance which you can solve in
polynomial time
there are some also trivial clauses say
satisfiable by all zero assignment or
satisfied by all one assignment
and these one two three four
five classes
one two three
four five
i'm basically covering everything that
you can think of in terms of
the natural restriction on sat and
stay in polymer time and that was proved
formally by shaffer who said exactly the
following
he says consider any sad variant whose
clauses are
of the same type among the few types
that i
discussed earlier then the if
all of the clauses are the same type you
have a polynomial time solvable set
variant
otherwise meaning if you allow clauses
of different types
to be present in the same formula the
complexity of satisfiability jumps
you get empty completeness
proof idea you consider ovarians
so of course i won't go through all the
possibilities here but
i want to give you a simple proof idea
for
a simple case suppose
you mix a clauses of the type
dual horn remember dual horn clauses
are those which have at most one
negative literal in it so all positive
literals is fine
as long as the number of negative
literals is smaller than at most one
so say we make still horn clauses and
with
two clauses then schaefer says that we
can express empty complete properties
and the complete problems
and indeed we can express a well-known
and the complete problem
three colorability so what is the color
ability to remind you given an
undirected graph
g and you want to know if there's a
coloring which is an assignment
of colors red green blue to your
vertices
such that every edge is colored with
two distinct colors on its endpoints
okay so can you three color a given
graph
well known as the complete problem shown
early on
and it's not difficult to express and uh
this
problem using the following constraints
so for every vertex you need to say that
it must be colored by one of the three
colors
so let's introduce prepositional
variables uh
r sub v which is true or false depending
whether the vertex v
is colored red g sub
v which is true or false depending if
the vertex v colored
green and b sub v for blue
so the first constraint which is which
should be expressed for all possible
vertices in the graph just tells you
that every vertex must be assigned one
of the three colors
and notice that this clause is of size
3 but all literals in it are positive
so it's a dual horn kind of clause
okay so every vertex must be assigned
something
the other kinds of constraint impose the
restriction that
you don't have monochromatic edges
present so it says that for every edge
uv in your graph
it shouldn't be the case that both
endpoints
are same color red or same color
green or same color blue and this can be
formally expressed as the conjunction of
this clauses of with two
shown on the slide okay
and if you put together all these
constraints of type one and type two
then you'll get a complete description
of your
three color ability expressed as a cnf
formula and you notice that the cnn
formula has closed us up with three
but all the trails are positive so this
is dual horn and it has a bunch of
clothes with two
so you're mixing dual dual horn with
closest little bit too
and you get a formula for three
colorability so you're jumping in
complexity to
an np-complete problem if you start
mixing like that
okay so that's the idea of cheverus
result
and so in general not only sat
and its boolean analogs or variants
uh that has this property that you have
black and white kind of picture
you either polymorph time solvable or
unp complete problem but
similar dichotomy result also holds for
non-boolean set variance
an example of a non-boolean set variant
is three color ability non-boolean means
that
you assign variables not necessarily
boolean values so you can express three
color ability as saying
a vertex gets a value color one
two or three so you can have non-boolean
um
alphabet uh to to work with and this
kind of cytherians of
non-boolean alphabets of non-binary
alphabet are also known as constraint
satisfaction problems or csps
and there's been a long line of work
trying to prove
the analogue of chef shaffer's result
for general csp
over arbitrary constant size alphabets
and only very recently a few years ago
by bullet oven zhuk
the result was proofed so now we know
that dichotomy theorem also holds for
non-boolean
csps generalizing the result of shaffer
from
the 1978.
so sat is very special great
suppose you have a sad algorithm now
what can you do with it
well one of the basic things you can do
if you have a set algorithm
is to find a satisfying assignment when
one exists
and this is known as a search to
decision reduction for satisfiability
it's a very basic thing uh let me
describe it to you
you have two problems on the right hand
side you have
sad which you think of as a decision
version of sound decision in a sense you
just
need to decide given a formula if it's
satisfiable or not satisfiable so give
me one bit of information about the
formula
yes satisfiable or no not satisfiable
more interesting problem of course is to
actually get your hands
on a particular satisfying assignment
for a given formula five
so you're given a formula five in such
search and you want to
output some maybe lexicographically
first but doesn't matter
some assignment to the variable such as
the formula lays to true under that
assignment so you want to find some
satisfying assignment
of course if the formula is not
satisfiable this is not possible
then you have to say no i cannot do that
so
can you solve such search if you know
how to solve sat
and the answer turns out to be yes and
the algorithm is pretty simple
so the result can be expressed as
sat search can be done in polynomial
time
with oracle access to sat
meaning that if you have if you give me
a black box
that i can query and ask sad questions
to
then given this query black box
i can answer some search using the
following algorithm
given here in this green box on the
slide
which is essentially binary search where
you use
your sub decision algorithm to
divide your space of possible satisfying
assignments
into half into two equal parts each time
and you just zero in on a satisfying
assignment
very quickly because you only need to
repeat this
log number of steps log number of
iterations where log is
log of the size of the search space you
only have to the n
um possible candidates
uh for satisfying assignments so log of
2 to the n
is like n iterations and indeed this
algorithm does exactly that
it runs in n iterations so let's just
look at this
pseudocode for the algorithm so the
algorithm for such
search is the following given formula
phi in n variables
here i'm being vague uh what my formula
5 is it can be a 3 c and
f it can be a circuit it doesn't really
matter
similarly what sound decision problem
i'm talking about is
not particularly important here it can
do 3c and fsat or circuit set
we know that they're all equivalent if
you if you if you can do one then you
can do the other
their reductions so whatever your
favorite
version of sat uh please
pick that okay so given such a fi
uh if i is not satisfiable then you
output no
and this is my uh first
uh oracle call to my sat oracle in this
algorithm
okay otherwise the formula 5 is
satisfiable so you try searching for a
satisfying assignment
one bit at a time so you assign you want
to find an assignment
a1 through a n to your variables x1
through xn
starting with a1 you try the value
0 for a1 and you ask the question if i
plug in
0 for the variable x1 and look at the
restricted formula
where the other variables are free and
x1 is replaced with a constant 0.
is the new restricted formula still
satisfiable if yes
then i'll just pick and fix that 0 for
the first
variable and if it's not satisfiable but
it was satisfiable i know it should be
satisfiable and
variable zero uh value zero for the
first variable does not work
then it must be the case that the first
variable is one
in all possible satisfying assigns for
the formulas and so i fixed my
a1 to be one in that case and recurse
okay so more precisely i have this for
loop
and i try uh
fixing the either of
the i variable in my formula five with a
constant starting with a zero
and if that works this is my another sat
oracle call here
if that makes the formula satisfiable
then i'm very happy
and i freeze my variable my value
of a1 of a i to be zero
otherwise if this formula with zero
plugged in
in the eighth place is not satisfiable
then i know that
the variable in that position must be
equal to 1
and so i freeze my a i to be equal to 1
in this case
and i continue for the next position
index
i once i'm done with this for loop
i output the found frozen values for the
bits a1 through am
and it's guaranteed to be satisfying
assignment based on the algorithm which
is pretty simple to see
okay so it's wonderful that if you have
a set algorithm for answering decision
problem questions
then you can also find object of
interest to you like satisfying
assignments or free colorings and graphs
and so forth
sound is fantastic but some properties
um
need more than just sat okay
and you can express some properties
using alternating quantifiers
so let's talk about uh alternating
quantifiers that help you to express
more interesting properties than just
simple stat first of all
um sat can be viewed as asking the
following kind of questions
you have a formula phi in x1 for xn
and satisfiability is nothing but asking
is there an assignment
so you have a bunch of existential
quantifiers there is there exist x1
there exists x1 and so for there exists
xn
such that phi of x1 through xn is true
you can also look at the universal
quantification of your variables
and then what you're asking about is is
the formula phi
true under all possible assignment which
is the same as asking is the formula
a tautology propositional tautology it
is true no matter which assignment you
plug in
and the two problems are kind of dual of
each other jewels of each other
you can easily see that phi
is a tautology if and only if the
complement the negation of phi that is
is
not satisfiable
okay so the two problems are very
related
and while sat is a problem complete for
the class
and p as we've seen the problem
tautology
is complete for the class complement of
np
denoted as coin p okay
and we think that sat and tautology
have a different expressive power
and we don't know whether you can take a
coin p
problem like tautology and put it in a
class
mp so can you reduce tautology to start
somehow
that would be like saying is it possible
that every tautology
have does this is it true that every
tautology
has polynomial size witnesses polynomial
size proofs
so is there a proof system that allows
you to prove
any every tautology using polynomially
short proofs only and that would be true
if it was the case that np and coin
p are the same and so the question
whether np is equal to coin p
has been a motivating question and it
was the initial question to motivate
proof complexity where people study
different proof
systems a less general than you know
the most general one captured by the
class mp itself
and try to study the relative expressive
powers of those
proof systems and proving that
different proof systems are not that
powerful that there are certain
tautologies that cannot be proved in
those proof systems
or if they can they require quite long
proofs
super polynomial or exponential size
proofs and of course
sat and proof complexity are very much
related and we'll hear
much more about proof complexity in this
workshop and the boot camp as well
one small observation here is that
if np is equal to p then
it's very easy to see that coin p is
also going to be equal to
p so coin p in that case would be equal
to p equal to
to np and so the contrapositive
would say that if np is different from
coin p
then np is different from p
so we have a conjecture that np is
different from coin p
this is the conjecture that people in
proof of complexity are trying to pursue
so what this observation says is that
to prove the conjecture that np is
different from coin p
would imply that would imply the proof
that
p is different from nt so proving np is
different from quantity is even harder
than just showing than just showing that
sat is not in polynomial time
so what can you do with one with
alternation of quantifiers
let's look at the special case of sigma
2 it's called sigma 2 because
you have two quantifiers that's what two
corresponds to and sigma means that you
start with existential
so you look at formulas as of the
following kind
okay so you think of deciding the
following property so sigma two property
is to decide the following
given input x you want to know if the
following
sigma to formula is true or not if there
exists a y
such that for all that w of x
y and z is true where w is some
polynomial time computable predicate and
y's and z's like in the case of np are
kind of witnesses or call witnesses
and the length of this witnesses is
polynomially bounded in the length of x
so the lengths of y and z are at most
polynomial in
n
let me give you a very simple example of
a problem in sigma 2
circuit minimization so the circuit
minimization
problem is the following intuitively
i give you a boolean circuit of certain
size
and i want to know if there exists a
smaller
circuit which is equivalent to mine
okay so is my circuit minimal or is
there
a smaller circuit which does the same
thing as my circuit but it's a smaller
size
you can express this problem as follows
so given as input the description of a
circuit c that's what this
angular brackets here correspond to in
case you're wondering
you want to decide if there exists a
description of a smaller circuit
d of size strictly less than c such that
c and d are equivalent which means that
on all possible input set
c and d assume the same value on those
symbols
and so this formulation can be viewed as
sigma two formula because you on input
on some input the circuit description
you're existentially guessing some
polynomial long string the description
of circuit d
then you're universally guessing uh
ambition
and then you're checking in polynomial
time whether two circuits c
and d assume the same value on a given
input
string set and circuit value problem
fortunately is in polynomial time given
a circuit you can plug in the
values for the inputs and just evaluate
the circuit gate by gate so it's very
easy between problem of time
and that's why the whole thing down here
is in polynomial time
and so you get a sigma 2 definition for
your problem
and you can generalize and you can go to
k alternations
in a straightforward way and then
polynomial time hierarchy
is defined as any constant number of
alternations so it's a union of sigma
case
for all constants k there's also
pi version which is the complement of
sigma
okay
so very interesting result in complexity
not very difficult but
very interesting result is to say that
if i have a polynomial time algorithm
for sat
then i can eliminate this quantifiers
from any page formulation or any page
problem that i have in mind
so in particular if status and
polynomial time then i can solve circuit
minimization problem that i earlier
defined
which is sigma 2 problem in polynomial
time
okay and the idea
is kind of simple
but it it's very subtle as well so let
me try to explain
the proof of this theorem uh
so we assume that sat is in polynomial
time might as well assume that circuit
satisfiability is
in polynomial time so let's take
script a to be a polynomial time
algorithm that solves circuits at
good i'm only going to show the collapse
of sigma 2 to polynomial time rather an
arbitrary level of the problem of time
hierarchy to keep things simple
but this will illustrate the idea nicely
so with a sigma 2p kind of problem it's
the problem where you give an input x of
length n
and you want to decide if this for the
following formula there exists y
rolls at some polynomial time predicate
w on
xyz is true
now we get to use our algorithm to
circuit construction that we use to
prove cook levin's theorem
remember we argued that if i have a
polynomial time algorithm or
more general algorithm running in time t
then we can
efficiently construct a circuit of size
roughly t or t
log t to be precise that will be
functionally equivalent
to the polynomial time computation to
this algorithm machine
so let's run this construction that
given w spits out a circuit c
which is functional equivalent to w on
all inputs x y and z
so this reduction r sub w can be done in
polynomial time
now we can just replace w that we had
in this place with functional equivalent
circuit c
so now we have the problem to decide if
there exists y for all z such that
circuit c on xyz is
true is one and
now let me just think about the internal
part
here as a kind of a separate problem or
rather i should
also include the last part okay so let
me look at the inside
uh problem here so kind of ignoring
quantification over y and just look at
x and y both as inputs and i want to
know
if for all that c of xyz
okay to make it a bit nicer
i will again take x
y which i'm taking now as input
variables and hardwire them into my
circuit c
so that my circuit c now depends only on
that
as the variables and now when i look at
this portion
of my formula what does it remind me of
it's for all that c of that for some
circuit
c and this is like tautology
question okay it's exactly circuit
tautology question
uh i can answer sat so i can also answer
tautology
questions as noted before and i have the
algorithm script a
for answering such questions so i can
just plug in this algorithm
to answer the tautology for circuit c
sub x y and so their existence of y
such that the statology is true is
equivalent to
the existence of y such that my sub
algorithm
says that the circuit negation of c
sub x y is not satisfiable
you know c statology if this negation is
not satisfiable
as we mentioned earlier
so what happened uh i had quantification
over sets for all that something
and now it's gone i've completely
eliminated this quantifier of those over
that's
and i can think now of this part
after the existential quantifier over y
as a polynomial time algorithm
which only depends on x and y i call
this new algorithm
w prime and the w prime
will be basically will be exactly this
okay
so w prime will take my input m will
construct the circuit c
and then we'll plug in x and y into the
first two inputs of that circuit
and then we'll run the satisfiability
algorithm on the resulting circuit c
sub x y actually on the negation of this
circuit
and the time complexity of this new
algorithm w prime
is not difficult to compute so to
compute w prime you run
sat algorithm script a so on what input
on the input
circuit c sub x y how big is the circuit
c sub x y
well we know it's basically the running
time of our original predicate w
or tilde is a convenient like notation
to use to hide this
extra log factors so time a is basically
quasi-linear in time of the procedure w
on input n so what we have is that
if w was in polynomial time and
sat algorithm a runs in polynomial time
the composition of two polynomial times
is polynomial
and so the running time of w prime is
still polynomial but it's growing
um we're not done yet so now we have
this
exist polynomial time computation which
is basically np
question we have assat algorithm that we
want to use to answer this question
so we can do the same thing as we did by
running kuklevin's theorem on
w prime now and getting a new circuit
c prime and
replacing w prime of x y with c prime of
x y and then
we have the question like this which is
satisfiability question of the
for the circuit c prime with x hardwired
and now to solve this that question we
again use our algorithm from script a
but now on the circuit c prime sub x
and if you put things together so we now
solve the problem in polynomial time
exactly what polynomial time so what is
the final
running time we get for the final
procedure
well here we apply algorithm a
to the input c prime what's the size of
c
prime it's the size it's roughly the
time
of the procedure w prime that c prime
came from
using kuklev's reduction and by plugging
in what
time of w prime was earl from earlier
we get that we can replace time w prime
with time
sub a of time sub w of n
so the point is that you have now
composition
of this sat around times
which shows you that you can apply this
kind of procedure
only so many times because you start
with w
here which has polynomial time and then
you apply
your sat algorithm which us up blows up
this time
more by polynomial amount and then you
apply your time algorithm to this
new blown-up formula you get even
bigger but still polynomial time it's
still polynomial
as long as you don't repeat this process
more than constant number of times
fortunately for polynomial time
hierarchy the number of quantifier
alternations is only constant
so that's okay you can handle constant k
in this proof argument
and another to me even more interesting
perhaps comment is that
it's very important here to have white
box access to start algorithm a
so you see
when you apply when you build this
procedure that finally answers sigma two
questions
you start by the original predicate
algorithm w and then you convert it into
a circuit and then you run the sat
algorithm on the circuit
and then you plug in the sat algorithm
into w prime
and then you run sat algorithm on the
circuit obtained from this new algorithm
and so you need to know the code of the
sub algorithm
to run this procedure it's not enough
for you to have to only black box access
to the sat algorithm
and that's what i mean by we need white
box access to start algorithm a
as opposed to black box access that was
enough for us
to solve such search the soft side
search black box access site algorithm
is enough to do it in polynomial time
but our proof
does not seem to show does not show that
polynomial time hierarchy
can be solved in polynomial time with
only black box
oracle access to sat
okay we'll come back to that
in a moment